>> Tucker: WE STILL DON’T KNOW
WHERE THE CORONAVIRUS CAME FROM
ORIGINALLY IN WUHAN, AND ANYONE
TELLS YOU WE ARE CERTAIN OF THAT
IS LYING TO YOU.
BUT MANY BELIEVE IT COULD HAVE
ORIGINATED IN THE WET MARKET IN
WUHAN WHERE CONSUMERS BUY THE
MEAT OF WILD ANIMALS TO EAT
INCLUDING BATS.
WILD ANIMAL WET MARKETS HAVE
LONG BEEN RECOGNIZED AS A MAJOR
PANDEMIC THREAT.
CHINA ANNOUNCED THEY WOULD CRACK
DOWN BUT IT LOOKED LIKE IT
DIDN’T LAST LONG.
ACCORDING TO DAILY MAIL, ACROSS
CHINA, WET MARKETS ARE REOPENING
AND SELLING THE SAME ANIMALS
THEY DID BEFORE.
DOGS AND CATS ARE BOTH FOR SALE
AS FOOD, AND A STAND SELLING
TRADITIONAL CHINESE MEDICINES
ADVERTISES THINGS LIKE LIZARDS,
SCORPIONS, AND BATS.
AGAIN, WE HAVE KNOWN FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE THAT WET MARKETS
ARE A DISEASE TIMEBOMB.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST VIRUS TO
EMANATE FROM THEM.
LOOKS LIKE EVEN AFTER A GLOBAL